two times I've been searched at the
airport and I had weed in my bag and I
was 15 and I was 18 and I almost ran on
the 15 one but then I thought where am I
going because of the Portland airport
and I put two Zips in my suitcase and my
dad dropped me off and he was all happy
and she like yeah you're doing really
good man I got kicked out and had to
move to Oregon
and I had two Zips and then as they're
searching my bag I'm like well that's it
I'm gonna I'm in trouble it's a federal
building yeah it's 15 like oh it's over
they looked over it they opened they
searched my bag and everything didn't
even they got to like it was under a
blue striped shirt and I remember it was
like the seventh shirt down they get
there I put remember a long movies on
VHS were two two yeah two tapes all
right so I had the American Beauty when
it was two yeah so I put Tuesday yeah I
put two Zips in it I was like ah [__]
yeah but I made it they opened it okay
you're good and zipped it up and like my
throw up went back down